Donald Trump's approval rating continues
to drop down to 37% over the weekend and
you'll notice on this graph that we have
that when Donald Trump came into office
his approval rating was quite low
already it dipped in mid-february and
then it rebounded in early March the
approved line of course the lighter
green line on the bottom if you're
looking at this chart with me rebounding
in early March
but then falling off of a cliff
precipitously and this is from the
Gallup presidential tracking poll this
is based on a three day rolling average
and sometimes you'll hear o drudges
linking a Rasmussen I got to go into my
Alex Jones voice when I even talked
about Drudge or Rasmussen and it says
this today or there's an isolated NBC
Wall Street Journal poll that had this
approval rating yesterday Gallup has
been doing this the same way for decades
with with consistent methodology and
here's where context helps us understand
how bad 37 percent were basically two
months 60 days into the presidency March
20th Trump inaugurated on January 20th
many presidents have had at different
points of their presidencies lower
approval ratings than 37% for example
George W Bush got down to 25% at one
point Bill Clinton was down to 37%
George HW Bush down to 29 Reagan hit 35
Obama not really on this list because
his lowest throughout his eight years
was 40% but this is the first time in
the last 70 years that a president has
been this low at this point in their
first term check out the comparison as
to where other presidents were 60 days
into office Jimmy Carter had 75%
approval 60 days into office Ronald
Reagan had 60% approval 60 days into
office George HW Bush 56% Bill Clinton
53% George W Bush 58 Obama 63 and Donald
Trump as you notice here 37%
60 days into office you know what the
real shock is to me Pat more than one
out of three Americans approves of the
job that
is doing that's the stunner if you
randomly select three people from the US
of course they'd be influenced by what
state are you grabbing them from or
whatever but big picture out of three
random people in the US more than one
thinks Trump is doing a good job to
which the obvious response should be
what is Trump doing that you approve us
and I think most presidents would look
at those numbers and think all right I
have to be less bombastic I have to act
more presidential maybe be more moderate
but I think he rationalizes not doing
any of those changes by saying I have
the space of supporters they're going to
be with me no matter what and it was
good enough to get me elected the first
time maybe it will work again what we're
going to see how big or small that base
is right because if the numbers go from
45 to 42 to 40 40 to 37 how big is the
base that will stick with Trump as he
said even if he shot people on Fifth
Avenue relevant question what's the
impact of a 37 percent approval rating
70 years low 60 days into office and why
does it matter it matters because you
have a Republican House and Senate and
mostly Republican governors and if
Donald Trump's approval rating doesn't
recover you may start to see Republican
elements jumping ship now I want to I
want to give a caveat and I've been
doing this increasingly because I think
it's relevant if Donald Trump being in
the White House will provide Republicans
cover so that they can push their
legislative agenda through as they've
been doing and we've been covering the
Republican bills Republicans may just
allow Trump to continue I think that
what will make Republicans publicly jump
ship from the Trump train Pat would be
if they need to in order to help their
own re-election chances either in 2018
or 2020 even if they disagree with Trump
as long as they can have the media
mostly pay attention to what Trump is
doing and pass their insane bills
they're probably happy to just do that
right but a lot of these Republicans
have to go to these town halls now and
you hear from their constituents and
they're very upset with what's going on
and sometimes the Republicans will
concede the point that they want to see
Trump's tax returns or or that there may
be something to these whole Russian s
investigations yeah but when they come
when it comes to a vote
don't write oh we should see the tax
returns a vote then it's cast as to
whether to try to push the tax returns
public not a single Republican votes in
favor of its exact point Oh going to
make oh well sorry I preempted out there
uh yes so I I don't know do you where do
you see the approval rating going
there's people who say David it's going
to stay between 37 and 45 and he'll have
a shot at reelection just like Bush did
with a roughly forty five forty six
percent approval rating others keep
emailing me saying David it's going into
the 20s it's really hard to predict
because so much of it is determined by
the events that go on within his
presidency and so much of that you can't
control if there's some big travesty
well we will be following it I don't
think 37 percent is below but I'm not in
the camp that's sure it will drop below
25 because I think that the I'll support
Trump even if he shoots people on Fifth
Avenue contingent may be bigger than
some people are giving credit for